yo what's up everybody mad luigi here
and today i'm gonna be talking a little
bit more about fallout 4 and now in this
video I'm gonna be talking about the
fallout 4 launch trailer and the fallout
4 map as we can see it from the pip-boy
app that Bethesda has released now the
launch trailer is if you haven't heard
about it Bethesda has released a launch
trailer to get people hyped for Fallout
4 which comes out as we know November 10
and there's actually a lot of cool stuff
happening in the trailer there's a lot
of cool weather a lot of really good
looking shots more gameplay more
gunfights more characters more story
more everything it's a really cool
trailer and you haven't seen it I really
highly suggest you go check it out I
could make a video that kind of just
analyzes the whole trailer and goes
through everything however mr. Maddie
plays which is a much bigger fallout 4
youtuber than me and just youtuber in
general not specifically fallout 4 I
guess he's really big and followed
though he made a great analysis of the
trailer and I really highly suggest you
guys go watch that too if you're looking
for an analysis and because i don't
think i can do justice with what he's
already done so i'm just gonna link you
guys to him if you want a analysis for
i'm just letting you guys know that it
exists it's really fun i really thought
it was really cool and yeah that's about
it for the launch trailer since it's
just awesome to go watch it if you
haven't and if you have watchin you want
analysis go check out mr. mattock please
now what I want to talk about is the
fallout 4 map a lot of people are well I
guess I should tell you first we have a
full picture of the map like completely
one hundred percent real not leaked it's
confirmed because Bethesda the full
company Bethesda has released a pip-boy
app and if you guys don't know then the
special edition of fallout 4 comes with
a pip-boy like your actual wrist fit
boyd and you can put your phone into it
load up this pitboy app and it can
connect it to your game and it's like
having a pip-boy in real life now they
have released the app even though
everybody doesn't have the game yet so
if you don't have the game yet like
ninety nine percent of people then you
can just play in demo mode and from demo
mode is where people stitch this map
together as you can see the map says
demo mode a lot that's because it was
all taken from the pip-boy just little
phone screen and so they just took
screenshots of it they stitched together
and here we go a lot of people are kind
of concerned that they think it's small
they don't think it's as big as it
should be there are some size
comparisons with Skyrim saying that oh
it's not as big as Skyrim so
a lot of stuff that I want to talk about
another map and people's concerns that I
don't think are two founded today we
compared to Skyrim sky did kind of have
horses and there were kind of giant
mountains that weren't really made to be
walked through for a lot of the map and
there's a lot of side just stuff on the
map that you don't go to so there's a
lot of that so comparing to the skyrim
isn't really a good precedent and also
people concerned just straight up about
it being too small there's a lot this
map doesn't take into account for like a
lot of all the dungeons buildings and
things that you go into or go
underground this map doesn't show all
that and all of that is going to be a
huge amount of gameplay so I don't think
we can make any judgments about the map
based on just this one flat picture that
we see with no markers on also I want to
comment that a lot of the map is water
which I actually find really exciting
because that means we're gonna have a
lot more to do with water a lot of the
previous photo games haven't had much to
do with water and because so much of
this map is water and there's now perc
specifically for water the I think it's
endurance 5 aqua boy I think it's called
that gets me really excited because it's
just a lot more stuff to do in water
which we haven't really experienced
before and I think it's going to be a
really cool experience so that's most of
the stuff that I wanted to talk about i
think i'm really excited by both launch
trailer and just map I think you guys
should be to you guys have enjoyed this
video make sure you check out my more
for more of my fallout 4 content i will
be posting a lot more and i have posted
to get them out already and yeah thanks
for watching I hope you have enjoyed and
see you later peace out